pupils return to english schools on
tuesday after the christmas break and
the head teacher at richard challen a
school in south west london is worrying
about staff absences i've had four staff
email me saying they'll be in isolation
and beginning a term now we can manage
that but if that becomes 10 staff or 12
staff we've got huge problems and not
for the first time in the pandemic
english schools are implementing last
minute policy directives from the
government all high school students must
now wear masks in classrooms i like all
the other head teachers around the
country found out about when masking
classrooms for lessons when we read the
national newspapers on sunday morning
which is appalling in my view how is it
that the press know what is going to go
on in the classroom before her teachers
have even been briefed on that but this
is the only real tweak to boris
johnson's omicron gamble while scotland
wales and northern ireland all brought
in restrictions before christmas the
prime minister chose not to for england
he's sticking with his decision
the wayfall for the country as a whole
is to continue with the path that we're
on the gamble is that vaccine coverage
and omicron's relative mildness will
prevent the health service from being
overwhelmed but even boris johnson
recognizes it's not looking good
the pressure on our nhs on our hospitals
is going to be
considerable in the course the next
couple of weeks and maybe more because
as there's no question omicron continues
to to surge through the country
elsewhere in europe with the new year
come new steps france is going ahead
with measures announced last week a
three-day work from home rule for those
who can big public gatherings limited
for three weeks and parliament is
debating a change to france's health
past only the vaccinated would be
allowed in restaurants cafes and more
the health minister condemned alleged
death threats from anti-vaccination
activists
let us not lose sight of the fact that
the objective of this law is not to
restrict individual and collective
liberties of french people the objective
of this law is to save lives it is to
protect our hospitals and relieve the
workload of our health workers
despite opposition from some politicians
the backing of several parties means the
lower house will likely pass the bill
rory helens al jazeera